15 on your friday morning what's cool at
school how about close to 2 000
elementary school students teachers
parents attending the first ever concert
at the brand new dollar loan
center
the home of the henderson silver knights
hockey team is also home to the
henderson symphony orchestra where
students and their teachers from 10 ccsd
elementary schools and kids from two
area homeschool groups and their parents
saw and heard what for many was their
first ever symphony concert conductor
alexandra arietje it's very sweet and
represents everything that i think we
need right now it's our pleasure to show
some music for them to give that
experience and i know it's going to be
in their minds for the rest of their
lives the clever bouncy piece called the
animated orchestra included narration
from some guy on a bow tie about an
invisible ferret who nearly destroys the
orchestra
[Music]
audience participation range from sound
effects
to the way
it was followed by a young man plucked
from the audience to masterfully conduct
star wars
[Music]
all right
well thanks to the henderson symphony
the dollar loan center staff and the
clark county school district community
engagement folks who made it all happen
if you know something that's cool at
school let us know coolest schools under
the community tab at eightnewsnow.com or
just email cool at school at
eightnewsnow.com hendersonville played
at the old henderson pavilion for years
so to have to have them be the very
first musical event at the dollar loan
center wow it was it was a lot of
responsibility but it was also a ton of
fun what's it like to be in there i've
been in there yet it was it the we
weren't sure what it was going to look
like they didn't have a half curtain
down
for
but the ice was still there they had the
plastic tiles on the surface it was
chilly chilly i was gonna say